[Musique]
c'est une sombre histoire qui frappe le
paysage audiovisuel français il
semblerait qu'une malédiction frappe
touche pas à mon
alors que l'émission enregistre record
sur record cette saison un constat
alarmant effet les meilleures audiences
semblent liées avec l'absence d'un
chroniqueur emblématique de l'émission
Mathieu Delormeau
prête à sourire certains s'inquiètent
comme Franck Appietto le grand patron de
C8 j'ai remarqué que dès que Matthieu
n'est pas nain TPMP fait des record
historique mais laissez-le sur TPMP bon
sang alors avec ce nouveau record sans
Matthieu faut-il se poser des questions
[Musique]
à des mousses sont tellement
voilà pour conjurer le sortez alors
faut-il se poser des questions oUI NON
NON oui oui oui non oui je me suis
entretenu vous êtes déguisé en
dalmatiens
en fait ce qui ressort c'est que les
gens n'ont pas de problème avec son
physique mais un problème quand il prend
la parole donc les équipes réfléchissent
les équipes réfléchissent à lui enlever
son micro est-ce qu'il fasse acte de
présence et il pourrait remonter comme
ça dans le cœur des Français sortez
votre intervention est nul merci
[Applaudissements]
fais attention Benjamin Castaldi n'aime
pas les chiens et les chats
c'est la première fois que tu parles
autant lors d'un TPMP
c'est gentil contrairement à cette
petite séquence de la production quand
vous étiez contre bien sûr je t'écoute
je veux dire ce que tu en penses
t'inquiète pas bien sûr Béatrice tu dis
non moi je dis non
je dis non parce que moi je devais être
là pour 6 ou 7 des meilleurs audiences
en question et donc si je considère que
Mathieu porte la poisse je dois
considérer que je porte chance et ce
serait très prétentieux donc je dis non
pas mal
freinage ADS très bien merci j'ai merci
beaucoup rappelez-vous quand même que
j'étais là six ou sept fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Delphine bah en fait tout simplement
c'est mathématique à partir de plus de
deux fois c'est plus une coïncidence
d'accord donc voilà en fait faut se
poser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qui lève pas la jambe trop
allez merci
oui Géraldine alors moi quand Mathieu
n'est pas là il me manque j'aime toute
Matthieu je le trouve beau brillant
irrévérencieux impertinent et je pense
que c'est totalement le hasard
tu me considères comme un spécialiste de
télévision
si ça n'est pas le bazar il y a deux
raisons à mon avis d'abord
il est tellement charismatique Mathieu
que peut-être parfois il est trop
présent dans l'émission et que parfois
peut-être il nous écrase nous parce que
on a voulu personnalité
non parce que moi j'aime quand il est
quand il est trop quand il est tout pour
moi c'est un superlatif Mathieu et
j'aime j'aime qu'ils soient superlatif
et je veux surtout pas qui
c'est Chucky dans ton documental
là c'est l'exorciste non mais sans
déconner le gars il a mis à son
talkie-walkie frère il entend la
Guingamp sans déconner quand même un
moment j'écoute les pété moi j'ai cru
qu'il avait des tu as des remonté
gastriques j'ai failli reprendre un
malaise mon Cédric [__] mon chéri non
mais c'est pas grave t'inquiète pas fais
ce que tu veux on est donc il faut
surtout pas que Mathieu se la mettre en
veilleuse parce que sinon c'est plus
mature
et donc voilà donc après voilà je pense
que c'est aussi peut-être le alors pas
le bazar parce que vous êtes en
spécialiste et vous me dites que c'est
vraiment pas le hasard donc ok c'est
peut-être pas le hasard mais il
n'empêche que je préfère peut-être des
audiences un tout petit peu moins bonne
avec Mathieu bon ben donc c'est récupéré
le ballon quoi bah tu sais que le PSG me
perd souvent avec quand il a les trois
elle Neymar Messi Mbappé il joue
peut-être mieux
Mbappé je t'explique quand il joue tous
les trois pour moi le PSG joue moins
bien avec les trois
ça va on rigole oh ça va bene pour
laquelle je dis que on a besoin de
Mathieu c'est justement parce qu'on a
dit Dan et comme en Asie dan c'est à
dire vous en fait les audiences les
audiences elles ne sont pas liées à nous
à qui est autoris à tout le monde les
gens viennent pour qui maintenant
vous savez quand je fais quand je fais
la table c'est vraiment communiqué de
foot je mets les défenseurs les milieux
de terrain les attaquants et après je
vois si je mets castagner ou pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et tu vois au début tu vois c'est ça et
voilà je voulais que je vous dise il y a
déjà je mets Gilles Verdez non pour des
raisons de non mais pour me sentir
beaucoup
après après voilà moi je mets bien sûr
Raymond parce que c'est un de mes
meilleurs amis c'est par amitié que vous
le mettez oui
il est très beau
aussi plein de mes meilleurs amis donc
voilà Castaldi c'est un de mes meilleurs
amis mais vous mettez pas tout le temps
ouais mais parce que là
je te mets en fait j'essaie de voir ce
que de ce dont tu as besoin par moi et
j'essaie de voir à peu près ce que je te
mets alors justement là il m'a manqué un
peu c'est genre fait que deux cette
semaine ah et bah écoutez bah tu verras
hein t'inquiète pas tu as un petit
rallonge ah non non pas de moi de repas
tu peux pas refaire un petit comme
j'aime
[Rires]
tu peux me permettre j'ai un cadeau pour
vous depuis 3 ans ma mère et ouais et
c'est un vrai beau cadeau tu vas lui
donner t'inquiète pas
vous moi je vais pas dans votre merde
mais si elle t'adore
avec moi ouais mais occupe-toi d'abord
de deux leurs mots tu vois casser alors
moi je vais être franc avec Delormeau le
monde de la télé est à mon impitoyable
où il n'y a que des [__] donc je
fais partie donc de base il faut se
rendre à l'évidence tu as raté dit
record d'audience waouh donc c'est que
quelque part ta présence sur le plateau
soit elle gêne des gens ouais soit jeune
des gens soit tu en sais trop et je
rejoins peut-être
fermer ma gueule je vous jure que ça va
arriver
on va finir par Raymond mettez Mathieu
sur mute vous allez voir c'est pas la
même on va voir
il était sur il était même pas sur mur
Géraldine tu veux que je te dise ça ton
problème
tu penses comme une artiste et non pas
comme un homme d'affaires absolument je
te jure que c'est vraiment mais c'est
vrai ça me caractérise
tu vois
Castaldi il pense comme un mec qui aime
l'argent mais qui en a pas voilà
exactement c'est ça exactement
moi je suis pragmatique factuel et en
plus je suis un homme de chiffres donc
les chiffres comme ça 1-0 pour une
équipe si même l'autre équipe a bien
joué elle a un 0 à quand même gagné donc
ça veut dire que on joue mieux quand tu
n'es pas là c'est c'est factuel il y a
il y a un rejet je pense que les gens
[Rires]
les gens ne veulent pas que tu sois dans
les records d'audience à chaque fois il
a dit Benjamin dit ça aurait été deux
trois j'aurais dit bon hasard 10 quand
même Mathieu comment ça remarque
ça fait trois fois qu'on bat un record
quand Clara Morgane vient
c'est peut-être pas mal
Clara à côté de Mathieu à chaque fois
[Rires]
c'est pas de la housse c'est
vas-y non tu es très beau tu es très
beau là Géraldine toi qui connaît la
beauté
[Rires]
je te jure que tu es beau gosse
maintenant avec le beau comme ça
c'est que il est très beau comme ça je
viens de se réveiller il a
[Rires]
entre deux il a plus les cheveux longs
et il a pas les cheveux courts
exactement et donc l'entre-deux comme ça
je suis pas si tu me fais confiance
tu sais quoi moi je te vois en soirée je
craque pour toi d'accord
moi
c'est ma mère si ma daronne était
célibataire j'aurais présenté Gilbert je
te jure que c'est vrai mais j'irai pas
mais je te jure je trouve qu'il a un
truc et oui mais c'est quoi moi je
pourrais t'appeler mon beau-père non
mais non mais Gilles je te jure je te
trouve magnifique tu as pas la cote en
ce moment un petit peu oui ou pas
je te le jure je te regarde et là je
parle sérieusement je trouve que c'est
le plus beau de la table
c'est pas non plus il est plus beau
que les plus beaux castaïsme
quand même ouais voilà exactement Gilles
moi c'était celui qui me plaît le PLUS
d'abord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vous ai confiance et là vous faites
comme ça là je rigole ça va oh si on
peut plus faire Daphné j là
c'est lui qui a la plus belle voix aussi
non mais oh est-ce que ça toi aimer la
nouvelle coupe du coup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envoyé un texto à Patou pour savoir
ce qu'elle pensait de la nouvelle
aujourd'hui de Gilles elle m'a répondu
très simplement qui est cette personne
ah c'est gênant parce que Mathieu c'est
un ami ah bah oui forcément
tout ce que je vais dire ça va être jugé
c'est normal à l'aune de la renaissance
de notre amitié mais Cyril franchement
il faut vous débarrasser de lui
[Rires]
voilà les gars
voilà voilà
pourquoi voilà pourquoi gilbertez et le
premier de la classe les chéris voilà
pourquoi parce que c'est des variations
comme ça c'est magnifique on parlait de
foot parfois quand on a dans une équipe
quelqu'un qui est pas bon on dit on joue
à 10 vous savez mais avec Mathieu c'est
pire on joue contre notre camp contre
votre camp et Cyril les chiffres ne
manquent pas Mathieu je vous aime
beaucoup mais les gens ne veulent plus
de vous vous êtes rejeté par tout le
monde mais des des catégories entières
de la population ne veulent plus que
vous pourriez le monde entier
vous êtes un briseur de record au nom de
notre amitié dehors
ces produits
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je vais donner mon ex
je vais donner mon avis
en toute honnête tu es Cyril
sur l'inflation non sur les retraites et
ensuite je donne à mon avis sur Mathieu
Delormeau on a fait donner mon avis
Mathieu Delormeau je l'ai connu
j'avais rendez-vous avec lui on s'est
rencontré pour la première fois dans
dans mon bureau vous avez déjà de retard
j'avais deux heures de retard c'était un
test pour savoir s'il était assez motivé
pour me voir et effectivement il m'a
attendu et je me suis dit ce gars-là ce
gars là il a la foi
je peux dire ce que je pensais parce que
j'arrive dans le bureau on avait
rendez-vous à 16h30 je suis arrivé à
18h30
j'avais plein de trucs à gérer un match
de paddle qui a vraiment duré non non je
fais pas de paddle à l'époque mais c'est
vrai que ouais c'est vrai et donc
j'arrive et je le vois et là juste ce
qu'on appelle
un cdfp un cdfp CDF un coup de foudre
professionnel
j'ai dit ce mec là
tu veux il m'a marqué sur une enveloppe
comment il voulait il dit c'est bon tu
peux partir
et depuis
pour moi je le redis je n'ai pas peur de
le dire
tiens les plus grands talents de la
télévision française pour moi il fait
partie même je le dis bien en termes de
talon je pense vraiment
fait partie des trois plus gros talents
que j'ai vu dans ma vie alors que c'est
vrai fort je pense vraiment
non mais vraiment je le pense donc si le
talent doit nous priver d'audience et
bien écoutez je dis oui bravo
[Applaudissements]
oui je dis oui c'est un génie quand même
pas pourquoi le mec sort quand même
quand Mathieu est là on ne fait pas
d'audience mais comme c'est mon ami et
que j'aime les amis je le garde c'était
aimable
pourquoi l'homme qui est parti les trois
meilleurs visiblement s'il y a 10
records
je vais vous dire la vérité c'est parce
que on fait exprès de mettre des sujets
moins bons quand vous êtes là pour
pouvoir dire après les autres meilleurs
en fait il y a des gens qui vous en
veulent tu peux parler sans rire
et d'ailleurs j'aimerais qu'on dise tous
une petite gentillesse à Mathieu en un
mot moi je vais je vais commencer
connard
[Rires]
en un mot Mathieu c'est quoi
elle a une tenue on dirait une fleuriste
frère te demander des tulipes tes
couleurs
du jardin tu as une bête comme ça
normalement il y a un badge Eric Éric je
vais te voir une petite minute vous êtes
le métier oui toi attention j'ai dit une
gentillesse c'est très gentil mais même
si il comprend pas
c'est gentil
[Rires]
intéressant
Delphine arrête de te [__] de notre
gueule aussi intéressant
psychologiquement je trouve que c'est un
cas d'étude et c'est très intéressant
moi ça me plairait bien de dire
il est beau il est évolutif au fur et à
mesure du temps des alliés du mois de la
santé
quand on dit que quelqu'un est
intéressant ou quelque chose est
intéressant en anglais c'est jamais un
compliment
[Rires]
grande qualité humaine et j'ai toujours
reconnu ce qu'il a des très beaux
triceps franchement très bien dessiné
aujourd'hui
excusez-moi juste vous vous êtes à quel
rayon vous êtes au rayon piscine
pas un mot que j'aime bien c'est pas une
boisson
prétentieux et intéressant et l'autre il
a dit
oui machine de répartie
frère et je croyais qu'il allait sortir
un mot de ouf quand même
machine de réparer
il était hyper fier de sa sortie genre
il avait sorti un mot de
ouf maintenant c'est de la de merde mais
ça pue la merde ce qu'il a dit frère
mais non le gars il est comme un j'ai
perdu la boule noire avec tes conneries
non mais ça il est comme un frère
machine de repartir frère le gars il se
prend dans mot de passe tu sais non mais
sans déconner l'autre ça y est il s'est
pris il a cru qu'il avait eu un prix
Nobel il a conduit deux fois à 6 tonnes
il croit qu'un Méo descend mon vieux là
il y avait exemple
avec moi il a une tête comme ça
c'est à dire des bains on a barboté quoi
en un mot je vais résumer la pensée
vraiment difficile c'est extrêmement vif
difficile
j'adore j'adore j'adore j'adore
quoi je suis à deux doigts médiatique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]